it's the president president in office
of the council honorable members ladies
and gentlemen in eight months time
voters across Europe will judge what we
have achieved together in last five
years in these five years Europe has
been more present in the lives of
citizens than ever before Europe has
been discussed in the coffee houses and
popular talk shows all over our
continent today I want to look at what
we have done together at what we have
yet to do and I want to present what I
believe are the main ideas for a truly
repealed political debate ahead of next
year's elections honourable members as
we speak exactly five years ago the
United States government took over
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac bailed out
AIG and Lehman Brothers filed for
bankruptcy protection these events
triggered the global financial crisis it
evolved into an unprecedented economic
crisis and it became a social crisis
with dramatic consequences for many of
our citizens these events have
aggravated the debt problem that still
distress is our government they have led
to an alarming increase in employment
especially amongst young people and they
are still holding back our households
and our companies but Europe s fourth
back in those five years we have given a
determined response we suffer the crisis
together we realize we had to fight it
together and we did and we are doing it
if we look back and think about what we
have done together throughout the crisis
I think it's fair to say that we will
never have thought all of this possible
five years ago we are fundamentally
reforming the financial sector
so that people's savings are safe we
have improved why governments work
together how they return to sound public
finances modernize their economies we
have mobilized over 700 billion euros to
pull crisis trap countries back from the
brink the biggest effort ever
in stabilization between countries I
still vividly remember my meeting last
year with chief economies of many of our
leading banks most of them were
expecting Greece to leave the euro all
of them feared
to this integration of the euro area now
we can give a clear reply to those fears
no one has left or has been forced to
leave the euro this year the European
Union enlarged from 27 to 28 member
states and next year the euro area will
grow from 17 to 18 member states what
matters now is what we make of this
progress do we talk it up or talk it
down do we draw confidence from it to
perceive what we have started or do we
believe the result of our efforts
honorable members I just came back from
the g20 in st. Petersburg I can tell you
this year contrary to recent years we
Europeans did not receive any lessons
from other parts of the world on how to
address the crisis we received
appreciation and encouragement not
because the crisis is over because it is
not over but the resilience of our union
has been tested and you'll continue to
be tested but what we are doing creates
the confidence that we are overcoming
the crisis provided we are not
complacent we are taking our challenges
together and we have to tackle them
together because in our world of geo
economic and geopolitical tectonic
changes I believe that only together as
European Union we can give our citizens
what they aspire that our values our
interests our prosperity are protected
and promoted in the age of globalization
so now is the time to rise above purely
national issues and parochial interests
and to have real progress for Europe to
bring a truly European perspective to
debate with national consequences now is
the time for
those who care about Europe whatever
their political or ideological position
wherever they come from to speak up for
Europe
if we ourselves don't do it we cannot
expect others to do it either
honourable members we have come a long
way since the start of the crisis in
last year's State of the Union speech I
stated that despite all our efforts our
responses have not yet convinced
citizens markets or our international
partners one year on the facts tell us
that our efforts have started to
convince overall strands are coming down
the most vulnerable countries are paying
less to borrow industrial output is
increasing market Trust is returning
stock markets are performing well the
business outlook is steadily improving
consumer confidence is sharply rising we
see that the countries who are most
vulnerable to the crisis and are now
doing most to reform their economies are
starting to note positive results in
Spain as a signal of the very important
reforms and increased comparable exports
of goods and service now make up 33
percent of GDP more than ever since the
introduction of the euro Ireland has
been able to draw money from capital
market since the summer of 2012 the
economy is expected to grow for a third
consecutive year in 2013 and Irish
manufacturing companies are retiring
stuff in Portugal the external current
account which was structurally negative
is not expected to be broadly balanced
and growth is picking up after many
quarters in the red Greece has completed
just in three years a truly remarkable
fiscal adjustment is regaining
competiveness and is nearing
for the first time indicates a primary
surplus and Cyprus that started the
program later is also implementing that
program as scheduled which is a
precondition
for return to gross so my point is this
for Europe recovery is within sight
let's be realistic in analysis let's not
overestimate the positive results but
let's not also underestimate what has
been done of course we need to be
vigilant when swallow does not make a
summer nor one fine day even one fine
quarter does not mean we are out of the
economic heavy weather but it does prove
we are on the right track on the basis
of the figures and evolutions as we now
see them we have good reason to be
confident this soup to us to keep up our
efforts we owe it to those for whom the
recovery is not yet within reach to
those who do not yet profit from
positive developments we will reach to
our 26 million unemployed especially to
the young people and employ that are
looking to us and they want to have
reasons to feel hope about Europe and
about their own countries so hope and
confidence is also part of the economic
equation honourable members if we are
where we are today it is because we have
shown the resolve to adapt both our
politics and our policies to the lessons
drawn from the crisis and when I say we
I really mean we it has really been a
joint effort at each and every step you
European parlament
you may have played a decisive role
through one of the most impressive
records of legislative work ever
I personally believe this is not
sufficiently known by the citizens of
Europe and you deserve more credit and
recognition for this so let us continue
to work together to reform our economies
for girls and jobs and to adapt our
institutional architecture only if we do
so we'll leave this phase of the crisis
behind us as well there is a lot you can
still deliver together in these
Parliament's and this Commission's
mandate what we can and must do first
and foremost let's be concrete is
delivering the banking union it is the
first and most urgent phase on the way
to deepen our economic and monetary
union has mapped out in the Commission's
blueprint presented last autumn the
laser teeth process on the single
supervisory mechanism is almost
completed the next step is the ECB's
independent valuation of bank assets
before it takes a pitch supervisory role
our attention now must urgently turn to
the single resolution mechanism the
Commission's proposal is on the table
since July and together we must do the
necessary to have it adopted still
during this term it is the way to ensure
that taxpayers are no longer the ones in
the frontline for paying in the price of
bank failure it is the way to make
progress in the coupling bank from
sovereign risk it is the way to remedy
one of the most alarming and
unacceptable results of the crisis
increased fragmentation of Europe's
financial sector and credit markets even
an implicit reinitialize ation and it is
also the way to help restoring normal
lending to the economy notably to SMEs
because in spite
of the accommodative monetary policy
credit is not yet sufficiently flow into
the economy across the euro area this
needs to be addressed resolutely
ultimately this is about one thing
growth which is necessary to remedy
today's most pressing problem
unemployment the current level of
unemployment is economically
unsustainable politically untenable
socially unacceptable so all of us here
in the Commission and I'm happy to have
all my colleagues of the Commission
today with me all of us not only one or
two commissioners but it is a collective
effort all of us want to work with you
intensively to deliver as much of our
gross agenda our sustainable growth
agenda as we possibly can we are
mobilizing
all the instruments we have activity
level but of course we have to be honest
not all instruments are at European
level some of them are at national level
and I want to focus on implementation of
the decisions it are most crucial now
use employment and financing the real
economy for SMEs we need also to avoid a
jobless recovery Europe therefore must
speed up the pace of structural reforms
our country specific recommendations set
out what the Member States must do in
his respect and at European level
because there is what can be done at
national and what can be done at
European level the focus should be also
on what matters most for the real
economy exploiting the true potential of
the single market comes first we have a
well-functioning single market for goods
and we see the economic benefits of that
we need to extend the same format to
other areas mobility Communications
Energy Finance and e-commerce to name
that if you we have to remove the
obstacles that old back dynamic
companies and people we have to complete
connecting Europe I'd like to announce
that today we will formally adopt the
proposal
that gives a push towards a single
market for telecoms citizens know that
Europe has dramatically brought down
their costs for roaming our proposal
bill strengthens guarantees and lower
prices for consumers and present new
opportunities for companies we know that
in the future trade will be more and
more digital isn't it a paradox that we
have an internal market for goods but
when it comes to digital market we have
28 national markets how can we grab all
the opportunities of the future that are
opened by the digital economy if we
don't conclude this internal market the
same logic applies to the digital the
broader Digital Agenda it solves real
problems and improves the life for
citizens the strengths of Europe's
future industrial base depends on how
well people and business are
interconnected and by properly combining
the Digital Agenda with data protection
and defence of privacy our European
model strengthens the trust of the
citizens both with respect to internal
and external developments adopting the
proposed legislation on data protection
is of utmost importance to the European
Commission the single market is a key
lever for compare eveness unemployment
adopting our remaining proposals under
the single market act 1 and 2 and
implementing the connecting Europe
facility in the next few months we lay
the foundations for prosperity in years
to come we are also adapting to a
dynamic transformation on a global scale
so we must encourage this innovative
dynamism Italian scale that is why we
must also invest more in innovation in
technology and the role of science I
have great faith in science in the
capacity of human mind and capacity of a
creative society to solve its problems
the world is changing dramatically and I
believe many of the solutions are going
to come in Europe and outside Europe
from new science discoveries from new
technologies and I would like Europe
to be leading that effort globally this
is why we Parliament and Commission we
have made such a priority of our isin
2020 in the discussions on European
Union budget that is why you used
European budget to invest in skills
education and vocational training nine
amazing and supporting talents that is
why we have pushed for Erasmus plus and
that is why Leiter this autumn will make
further proposals for an industrial
policy fit for the 21st century
while we mobilize support for SMEs
because we believe a strong dynamic
industrial base is indispensable for a
strong European economy and whilst
fighting climate change our 2020 20
goals have set our economy on the path
to green growth and resource efficiency
reducing costs and creating jobs by the
end of this year we'll come up with
concrete proposals for our energy and
climate framework up to 2030 and we'll
continue to shape international agenda
by flashing out a comprehensive legally
binding global climate agreement by 2015
with our partners frankly we need yet us
also onboard Europe alone cannot do all
the fight against climate change we need
a level playing field a globally and we
should lead that effort at the same time
we'll pursue our work on impact of
energy prices on comparing us and also
on social cohesion all these drivers for
growth are part of our Europe 2020
agenda and fully and swiftly
implementing it is more urgent than ever
in some cases we have even to go beyond
the Europe 2020 agenda this means we
must also pursue our active and
assertive trade agenda
it is about linking us closer to growing
3rd markets and guaranteeing our place
in the global supply chain contrary to
perception when most of our citizens
think that we are losing in global trade
fact we have been increasing our surplus
to the rest of the world we have a
significant and increased trade surplus
of more than 300 billion euro a year in
goods in service and agriculture we need
to build on that these two will demand
our full attention in the months to come
notably with the transatlantic trade and
investment partnership with us and the
negotiations in Canada and Japan and
last but not least we need to step up
our game in the implementing the
multi-annual financial framework
European budget new budget is the most
concrete level we have attended to boost
investments in some of our region's the
European investment is the only way they
have to get some public investment
because they cannot now have the
resource every sources at national level
both between Department and the
Commission wanted more resources we have
been in that fight together
but even so let's be honest one single
ears you budget represents more money at
today's prices than the old Marshall
Plan in its time let us now make sure
that the programmes can start on the 1st
of January 2014 that the results are
being felt on the ground in our region's
across Europe and that we use the
possibilities of innovative financing
from instruments that have already
started to European Investment Bank
money to project bonds we have to make
good on the commitment we have made in
July from the Commission side we will
deliver we will for example present the
second amending budget for 2014 still
this month there is no time to waste so
I warned against holding it up in
particular I urge member states not to
delay I cannot emphasize this enough
citizens will not be convinced with
rhetoric and promises only but with a
concrete set of common achievements we
have to show the many areas where Europe
has solved problems for citizens Europe
is not the cause of problems Europe is
part of the solution I address what
you have to do steel more extensively in
today's letters to the president of
European Parliament which you will also
receive try not go now in detail
regarding our programme for next year
but my point today is clear together
there is still a lot to achieve before
the elections it's not the time to throw
down the towel it's a trial time to put
our sleeves up and work a lot honorable
members of course none of this is easy I
think that everybody recognizes that we
have been living extremely challenging
times a real stress test to the European
Union we know also that the path of
permanent and profound reform is as
demanding as it is unavoidable let's
make no mistake there is no way back to
business as usual some people believe
that after this every single comeback as
it was before they are wrong this crisis
is different this is not a cyclical
crisis but a structural crisis we will
not come back to the old normal we have
to shape a new normal we are in a
transforming period of history and we
have to understand that and not just say
it but to draw all the consequences for
this including in our state of mind and
how we react to the problems we see from
the first results that it is possible to
win that battle and we all know that is
not only possible that it is necessary
at this point in time with a fragile
recovery
the biggest downside risk I see is you
know what is political this is the
biggest downside risk
we have lack of stability or lack of
determination and perseverance over the
last years we have seen that anything
that casts doubt on government's
commitment to reform is instantly
punished on the positive side strong and
convincing decisions have an important
and immediate impact in this phase of
the crisis government's job is to
provide the certainty and predictability
that markets still like
I'm sure you all know Justus Lipsius
just ellipsis is the name of the Council
building in Brussels usually it was a
very influential 16th century humanist
scholar that wrote a very important book
called dare constantia he wrote
constancy is a right and immovable
strength of the mind
neither lift up nor press down with
external or casual accidents only a
strength of the mind he argued based on
judgment and sound reason can help you
through confusing and alarming times I
hope that in these times difficult times
all of us including the government
representatives that meet at reduced
ellipsis building show that
determination that perseverance and it
speak when it comes to the
implementation of the decisions taken
because one of the issues that we have
is to be coherent not just take
decisions but afterwards be able to
implement them on the ground honorable
members it is only natural that over the
last few years our efforts to over come
the economic crisis have overshadowed
everything else but our idea of Europe
needs to go far beyond economic economy
we are much more than a market the
European ideal touches the very
foundations of European society it is
about values and I underline these word
values it is based on a firm belief in
political social and economic standards
grounded in our social market economy in
today's world the European Union level
is indispensable to protect these values
and standards and promote citizens
rights from consumer protection to labor
rights from women's rights to respect
for minorities from environmental
standards to data protection and privacy
whether defending our interests in the
international trade securing our energy
provision or restoring people's sense of
fairness
by fighting tax fraud and tax evasion
only by acting as a union do we pull our
weight at the world stage whether
seeking impact for the development and
humanitarian aid we give to developing
countries managing our common external
borders or promoting Europe in Europe a
strong security and defence policy only
by integrating more can we really reach
our objectives there is no doubt about
it our internal coherence and
international relevance are inextricably
linked our economic attraction and
political traction are fundamentally
entwined does anyone seriously believe
that if the Euro had collapsed we or our
member states will still have any
credibility left internationally does
everyone still realize how enlargement
has been a success in terms of killing
history's deep scars in establishing
democracies where some years ago no one
had thought it possible
how neighbourhood policy was and still
is the best way to provide security and
prosperity in regions of vital
importance for Europe where would we be
all you know without all of this today
countries like Ukraine are more than
ever seeking closer ties to the European
Union attracted by our economic and
social model we cannot turn our back on
them we cannot accept any attempt to
limit this country's own sovereign
choices free will and free consent need
to be respected these are also the
principles that lie at the basis of our
Eastern Partnership which we want to
take forward at our summit in Vilnius
and thus everyone still remember just
how much Europe has suffered from its
wars during the last century and our
European integration was the valid
answer next year it will be one century
after the start of first world war a war
that tore Europe
from Sarajevo to the some we must never
take peace for granted we need to recall
that it is because of Europe that former
enemies now sit around the same table
and work together it is only because
they were offered a leap in perspective
that now even Serbia and Kosovo came to
an agreement under the mediation of the
European Union
last year's Nobel Peace Prize reminded
us of that historic achievement that
Europe is a project of peace we should
be more aware of it ourselves sometimes
I think we should not be ashamed to be
proud one thing is arrogance we don't
want to be arrogant but it should be
proud of Europe what we have achieved we
should look towards the future but with
the wisdom we gained from the past
let me say these to all those who
rejoice in Europe's difficulties and we
want to roll back our integration and go
back to isolation the pre integrated
Europe of the divisions the war the
trenches is not what people desire and
deserve European continent has never in
its history known such a long period of
peace as since the creation of the
European communities it is our duty to
preserve it and to deepen it honourable
members it is precisely with these
values that we address the unbearable
situation in Syria which has tested over
the last month's the world's conscience
so severely European and international
aid respond by mobilizing close to 1.5
billion euros of which 850 million euros
comes directly from the European Union
budget the Commission will do its utmost
to help the Syrian people and refugees
in neighboring countries we have
recently witnessed events we thought had
long been eradicated the use of chemical
weapons is a horrendous act that
deserves a clear condemnation and a
strong answer the international
community with the United Nations at its
centre carries a collective
responsibility to sanction these acts
and to put an end to this conflict the
proposal to put Syria's chemical weapons
beyond use is potentially a positive
development the Syrian regime must now
demonstrate that it will implement this
without any delay in Europe we believe
that ultimately only a political
solution stands a chance of delivering
the lasting peace that the Syrian people
deserve honourable members there are
those who claim that the weaker Europe
will make their country stronger yet
Europe is a border they will be better
off without it my reply is clear we all
need a Europe that is united strong and
open in the debate that is ongoing all
across Europe the bottom-line question
is do we want to improve Europe or give
it up my answer is clear
let's engage if you don't like Europe as
it is improve it find ways to make it
stronger internally and internationally
and you will have in me the firmest of
supporters find ways that allow for
diversity without creating
discriminations and I will be with you
of the way but don't turn away from it
I recognize as any human endeavor
European Union is not perfect for
example controversies about division of
labor between the national and European
levels you'll never be conclusively
ended I value subsidiarity highlight for
me subsidiarity is not a technical
concept it's a fundamental Democratic
principle and never closer Union among
the citizens of Europe demands that
decisions are taken as open and
transparently as possible and as closely
to the people as possible not everything
needs a solution at European level
Europe must focus on where it can add
most value where this is not the case it
should not meddle the opinion needs to
be big on big things and smaller on
smaller things something we may
occasionally have neglected in the past
the European Union needs to show it has
a capacity to set both positive and
negative priorities as all governments
we need to take extra care of the
quality and quantity of our regulation
knowing that as multi skill set Lily was
in little afib Lise Lille one SSL
useless laws weaken the necessary ones
but there are honourable members areas
of major importance where Europe must
have more integration more unity where
only a strong Europe can deliver results
I believe a political union needs to be
our political riser as I stressed in
last year's State of the Union this is
not just demand of a passionate European
this is an expensive all way forward to
correlate our progress and ensure the
future ultimately the solidity of our
policies namely of the economic and
monetary union
depends
on the credibility of the political and
institutional construct that supports it
so we have mapped out in the Commission
blueprint for a deep and genuine
economic and monetary union not only the
economic and monetary features but also
the necessities possibilities and limits
of deepening our institutional set up in
the medium and long term the Commission
will continue to work for the
implementation of its blueprint step by
step one phase after the other and I
confirm as announced last year the
intention to present before European
elections further ideas on the future of
our union and our best to consolidate
and deepen the community method and the
community approach in the longer term
that way these ideas can be subject to a
real European debate they will set out
the principles and orientations that are
necessary for a true political union
honourable members we can only meet the
challenge of our time if we strengthen
the consensus on fundamental objectives
politically we must not be divided by
difference between the euro area and
those outside it between the center and
periphery between north and south
between east and west european union
must remain a project for all members a
community of equals economically Europe
has always been a way to close gaps
between countries regions and people and
that must remain so we cannot do Member
States work for them the responsibility
remains theirs but we can and must
complement it with rulership in
responsibility and European solidarity
for that reason strengthening the social
dimension is a priority for the months
to come together with our social
partners the Commission will come with
its communication on the social
dimension of the economic and monetary
union on the 2nd of October solidarity
is a key element of what being part of
Europe is all about and something to
take pride on safeguarding its values
such as the rule of law is what European
Union was made to do from its inception
to the latest chapters in modular in
last year's state of didn't speech at
the mall
of challenges to rule of law in our own
member states I addressed the need to
make a bridge between political
persuasion and targeted infringement
procedures on one hand and what I called
nuclear option of article 7 of the
treaty namely suspension of the member
states rights experience as confirmed
the usefulness of the Commission role as
an independent and objective referee we
should consolidate this experience
through a more general framework it
should be based on the principle of
equality between member states activated
only in situations where there is a
serious systemic risk to the rule of law
and triggered by predefined benchmarks
the Commission will come forward with a
communication on this I believe it is a
debate key to our idea of Europe this
does not mean that national sovereignty
or democracy are constrained but we do
need a robust European mechanism to
influence the equation when basic common
principles are at stake there are
certain non-negotiable values that
European Union and its member states
must and shall always defend
honorable members depolarization that
resulted from the crisis poses a risk to
us all to the project to the European
project we legitimate representatives of
the European Union can turn the tide you
direct Democratic representatives of
Europe directly elected you will be at
the forefront of the political debate
the question I want to pose to you is
the following which picture of Europe
will voters be presented with the cannon
version or the cartoon version the myths
were the facts the honest reasonable
version or the extremist populist
version it's an important choice to make
I know some people out there will say
Europe is to blame for the crisis and
Archer but we can remind people that the
European Union was not at the origin of
the crisis it resulted from
mismanagement of public finances from
the national governments and the
responsible behavior in the financial
market we can explain how Europe has
worked to 60 crisis what we would have
lost if we had not succeed in holding
the single market because the single
market wasn't a threat and upholding the
common currency because some time ago
some people who are predicting the end
of the common currency if we had not
coordinated recovery efforts and
employment initiatives how would we be
now some people will say that it is
Europe that is forcing governments to
cut spending but we can remind voters
that government debt got way out of hand
even before the crisis not because but
despite Europe we can add that most
vulnerable in our societies and our
children would end up paying the price
if we don't persevere now and the truth
is at countries inside Europe or outside
Europe in Europe or outside Europe they
are making efforts to curb their very
burdened public finances similar
campaign saying that we have given too
much money to vulnerable countries
others will say that we have given too
little money to the most vulnerable
countries but every one of us can
explain what we did and why there is a
direct link between one country's loans
and another country's banks between one
country's investments and another
country's business between one country's
workers and another country's companies
this kind of interdependence means only
European solutions can work and what I
tell people is when you are in the same
boat one cannot say your end of the boat
is sinking we were the same boat when
things went well and we are in it
together when things are difficult
some people might campaign saying Europe
has grabbed too much power
others will claim Europe always does too
little too late Vince the interesting
thing is that sometimes we have the same
saying that Europe is not doing enough
and at the same time not not giving more
instruments for Europe to do what you
opposed to do but we can explain
that member states have interested
Europe with tasks and competences
European is not a foreign power European
Union is the result of democratic
decisions of the institutions and Member
States
at the same time we must acknowledge
that in some areas Europe still lacks
the power to do what is asked of it a
fact that is all too easily forgotten by
those and we know there are many out
there that are always ready to
nationalize success and to European eyes
fellow ultimately what we have and what
we don't have is the result of
democratic decision-making and I think
we should remind people of that ladies
and gentlemen mr. president honourable
members
I hope European Parliament will take up
this challenge with the old idealism it
holds with as much realism and
determination as the times demands of us
the arguments are there the facts are
there the agenda has been set out in
eight months times voters will decide
now except was to make the case for
Europe we can do so by using the next
eight months to conclude as much
can we have a lot to do still namely
adopt and implement European budget the
MFF this is critical for investment in
our region's all over Europe
this is indispensable for the first
priority we have to fight against
unemployment notably youth unemployment
another priority advance and implement
banking union this is critical to
address the problem of financing for
businesses and SMEs these are our clear
priorities employment and growth our job
is not finished it is in its decisive
phase because honourable members the
elections will not only be about
European Parliament nor will they be
about European Commission are about the
council about this or that personality
elections will be about Europe we will
be judged together so let us work
together for Europe with passion and
with determination let's not forget that
100 years ago Europe was sleepwalking
into the catastrophe of the war of 1914
next year in 2014
I hope Europe will be working out of a
crisis were united stronger and open I
thank you for our attention